foreign
ahead on Long crime daily the defense
continues its case in the Parkland
school shooter penalty phase trial was
there anything in
what you saw from the his behavior that
could have foretold this event happening
of what happened at Marjorie Stoneman
Douglas you're not in my opinion and
cross-examination gets heated when the
defendant grills his ex-wife on the
stand you did hold me down you did tie
me up you did attack me and you did
break into my home when I was sleeping
you raped me plus the death of Emily
Noble was it suicide or murder
[Music]
your formation in this image
any of the defamation that I see to that
nasal aperture is related to the
anti-mortem trauma and later after
fleeing the country and altering her
physical appearance defense attorneys
worried Caitlyn Armstrong will not
receive a fair trial long crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome every one to Long crime daily
I'm your host Terry Austin jurors in the
Parkland school shooter penalty trial
hear testimony from a clinical
psychologist who treated the gunman when
he was a young child long crimes and
Jeanette Levy is here to discuss what
the psychologist said about Nicholas
Cruz and Jeanette
well Terry Dr Frederick Kravitz is a
retired psychologist who actually
treated Nicholas Cruz when he was
between eight and nine years old he
diagnosed Crews with ADHD and
oppositional Defiance disorder he said
he also found features of autism in him
now Dr Kravitz testified that the
shooter's adoptive mother Linda told him
he could be sweet and affectionate but
wasn't really involved in a lot of
social activities he also testified that
Cruz's teachers were having difficulties
with him and that he was anxious and had
obsessive Tendencies but on
cross-examination prosecutor Jeff Marcus
asked whether any of that was really
relevant to what the shooter did at
Marjorie Stoneman Douglas High School on
Valentine's Day in 2018.
was there anything in
what you saw from the his behavior that
could afford told this event happening
of what happened at Marjory Stoneman
Douglas United in my opinion I've worked
with some other fairly damaged kids and
certainly uh to the best of my knowledge
and I'm the thing that procrastinate
now after
a neighbor of the cruises testified
about his Recollections of the family
Stephen schusler described an incident
he witnessed between his landlord and
Nicholas Cruz when he was 10 years old
and he also described what he saw when
he was running with an airsoft gun as a
child
she called him weird and yes he did not
have the
Boyhood image you could look at him and
you can see something's not right
something's off
his caricature
was
the first thing I saw was him was Alfred
E Newman
it was not a and a TR please and I'm
sorry to say this in front of the boy
but he was not attractive so he had this
thing in his hand and he's running like
this
but he had this
gone in his hand and he just
like that
oh okay I think that's sufficient is
there anything else you wanted to
demonstrate no that's it
all right so Stephen schustler went on
to say that he had met the shooter's
mother Linda Cruz but conceded he really
didn't know what was going on inside the
home Terry thanks Antoinette joining us
today is criminal defense attorney Karen
Felicia Nance and prosecutor Latonya
Hines LaTonya I'm going to start with
you the defense has called a number of
witnesses including this clinical
psychologist who treated Cruz when he
was a child so people were actually
aware of his psychological issues do you
think this mass shooting could have been
prevented based on the fact that so many
people knew about this
I mean this is the question we asked
anytime
um that there are all these different
sizes the question of whether or not
everybody is talking with each other all
at the same time to say hey we need to
get in treatment now we've heard that
there was some type of treatment going
on with it would we have thought that he
would have done this to this instant I
don't know
um but I think that they were telltale
signs that this uh individual definitely
was very very troubled and maybe there
needs to be more uh treatment or some
more inquiry about
okay thank you for that Karen we know
that the jury has to consider these
mitigating circumstances in connection
with the defendants very difficult
childhood but how do you think the
families in that audience are reacting
to all of this testimony
well actually Terry when the defense
attorney started her opening statement
the camera did Pan along the people
sitting in the in the audience and and I
believe most of them were family members
and they were looking had some of them
had fear in their eyes others I think
just unfathomable grief and others rage
and I think that that's totally
understandable their emotions are going
to be going up and down in addition they
were spared the the uh the horror I will
call it of having a regular trial for
the guilt phase but now we're in the
penalty phase so all those traumas that
they suffered are just being brought
back to them now so I think that that's
the saddest part about it is that
they're gonna have to sit through this
and they're having a difficult time of
it understandably I could not agree more
no question about it's got to be very
difficult sitting in that courtroom
Antoinette what else did this neighbor
Stephen schustler have to say about what
he witnessed during the six years he
lived near the cruises
well he described the shooter who was a
child then as somebody who just seemed
like he needs some needed some mentoring
he then described how um he and some
other children were hanging out with a
guy that he described as having a bit of
savoir fare I guess a little bit of
swagger if you will and that they were
smoking cigarettes and things like that
now these are all things that kids do as
teenagers or you know young young kids
not all but some do so he was trying to
say that look there was just something
off with this kid the whole time and
something more needed to be done that
was his impression he wasn't inside the
home as you heard thanks Anjanette for
that additional information still ahead
on Long crime daily Ohio versus Matthew
Moore the case of an alleged stage
suicide that investigators say was
actually a murder but first defendant
Trevor Summers opts to represent himself
while standing trial for the kidnapping
and attempted murder of his ex-wife
foreign
[Music]
welcome back a man charged with the
attempted murder of his ex-wife elects
to represent himself while his ex-wife
testimony is underway prosecutors say 45
year old Trevor Summers kidnapped his
wife back in 2017 and attempted to kill
her before a witness facilitated an
escape officials say Summers and Elisa
Matheson were in the midst of divorce
proceedings when he hacked a
murder-suicide plot they say Summers
held his wife captive in her home and
the back of her SUV attempted twice to
kill her on Tuesday Matheson described
the incident during direct examination
my hands are tied behind my back
and at this point
I'm again
this is where he is going to kill me and
that's what you're thinking at this
point and they're not going to find my
body because this is so secluded in such
a wooded area
so what happens
so he turned me around
and slit my wrist and said that's forget
now the car and the Walgreens
pushed me back into the car tied me back
to the seat
buckled me back in with my hands still
tied behind my back
on Wednesday Summers once again elected
to represent himself arguing he should
move forward with cross-examination
the Summers you have a request of the
Court sir yes sir what is it I would
like to resume self-representation and
discharge Mr marches League Council
and you believe that to be a wise
decision yes you're on our idea are you
unhappy with the services of Mr Marchese
uh
I'm not unhappy with the services of Mr
Marquez I do not believe that he fully
understands the circumstances
surrounding the events and it would be
better if I did the cross-examination
um from here on out
after that Summers moved forward with
the cross-examination of the witness his
ex-wife testimony got heated when
Summers asked about a sexual encounter
did I threaten you to have sex
broke into my home in the middle of the
night when I was sleeping I talked to me
and tied me up I take that as yes you
threatened me to have sex with you yes
I'm asking you specifically before we
had sex did I
threaten you or force you to have sex
my answer is yes you forced me to have
sex with you did I hold you down
no did I push you
not at that time of having sex but prior
to having sex you did push me you did
hold me down you did tie me up you did
attack me and you did break into my home
when I was sleeping you raped me
wow Karen let me start with you the
defendant has vacillated more than once
on this issue of self-representation now
that he's representing himself how do
you think this is affecting the victim's
testimony I mean right there she seemed
very upset
I agree totally Terry I think that this
was a plan all along I think that he had
plenty of time to come up with this idea
of having his attorney do the the leg
work to get to this point and then he
switched up because he wanted this
opportunity to cross-examine his ex-wife
what's the purpose to intimidate her to
discredit her and ultimately get her to
come off of her statement with the hope
that she would totally fall apart and
hopefully he by the skin of his teeth
would be able to convince the jury that
he shouldn't be convicted but I think
more so this was an opportunity for him
to show up for TV to show what he could
do and and have his life story
immoralized immortalized and I think
that that's what this is about well good
for her for standing up to him actually
he's not doing a bad job as an attorney
listen Latonya the defendant has
indicated that he wants to serve a
subpoena to call Elise back for his
direct case to raise a dish personal
issues that were not covered during
direct where do you think he's going
with this
I mean I think it's continued
victimization of the victim I mean how
many opera how many times does this
happen where a victim especially in a
case like this is having to confront the
person who is alleged to have caused the
issue right she's she's having to
confront and talk to and answer
questions to the person who's accused of
trying to kill her
um I think that is just continued
victimization and I think it's the fact
that he is a bit of a narcissist it's a
narcissistic way of keeping control it's
his way of controlling her couldn't
agree more no doubt about it listen
coming up on Long crime daily the woman
accused of murdering a professional
cyclist appears for a hearing in Texas
plus the state rests its case and calls
its final Witnesses in the Ohio case of
Matthew Moore as he faces charges in the
2020 stage suicide death of his wife
[Music]
welcome back the state rest its case in
the Ohio trial of Matthew Moore as he
faces murder charges in the death of his
wife Emily Noble Moore reported Noble
missing after her 52nd birthday in May
2020 hundreds of volunteers conducted
search parties to look for her over the
next few months though more reportedly
never took part in mid-september a group
of women found Noble's body in a wooded
area near the couple's home with a USB
Court tied to a tree branch and wrapped
around her neck her body was so badly
decomposed investigators had to use
dental records and DNA to confirm her
identity officials say her death was
staged to look like a suicide but they
believed evidence pointed to murder the
following June Moore was arrested and
charged with felony murder and felonious
assault a state witness testified that
damage to the victim's Gull suggested
there was injury to her face after her
death on Wednesday the defense's first
witness of forensic anthropologist
disagreed she testified Noble's injuries
are consistent with a suicide saying her
findings indicate most of the damage to
her face happened long before she died
tell the jurors about class
so classic deformation a lot of times is
an indicator for perimortem blunt force
trauma essentially when you have a load
applied to the Bone right the bone has
elastic a little bit of elastic
properties to it and if you were to stop
applying that force it would just go
back to the way that it was if you were
then to continue applying Force that's
when you get failure for that fracture
any of the deformation that I see to
that nasal aperture is related to the
anti-mortem trauma did you
use through the course of your review
that there was post-mortem damage in
this case the lacrimals are damaged
usually we're not going to have a big
hole there where does post-mortem damage
how does it happen
there's lots of ways when remains are
exposed to the elements there's animal
Scavenging Birds rodents anything that
is like post-depositional
Latonya the forensic anthropologist
testified that damage to Noble's face
was not recent and that it happened long
before she died why do you think that's
important for this jury to hear
because they're trying to show that
there is this idea that he didn't do
this after she died to try to you know
hide her real cause of death here's the
reality the defense has to do one thing
they just need to convince one person
that what they're saying is true or
better yet make one person doubt the
state's case all they need to do and so
they've got an expert witness and
they're trying to use that expert
witness to bring doubt as to when she
actually died and who actually is at
fault whether or not she did it herself
and whether or not he did it and their
thing is she he didn't do it this was
something either self-inflicted that
happened with her but they're put doubt
in the minds of the jurors at least one
juror that's all they need you know you
raise a very good point there the burden
is on the prosecution not the defense
but Karen this defense counsel is very
proactive she's actually putting
Witnesses on the stand how do you think
she's doing so far
I think she's doing an effective job she
most recently on on our show Law and
crime had been uh representing uh
William Hughes well Dr William heusel
with uh Jose Baez and so he was
acquitted of 14 counts of murder I think
that she's effective she's very
deliberate in her questioning of the
witnesses and also she is masterful and
will be successful because she is very
compelling and I I love watching her she
does an awesome job thanks for that
reminder I had forgotten about that
she's an excellent attorney listen when
we come back Caitlin Armstrong is back
in court what motion did the prosecution
and defense agree on in the case
welcome back the woman accused of
murdering a professional cyclist fleeing
the country and altering her appearance
to evade law enforcement appears for a
hearing in Texas back in June 34 year
old Caitlin Armstrong was arrested for
her involvement in the shooting death of
Mo Wilson Wilson whose real name is Anna
Mariah was shot and killed more than 40
days earlier investigators say she may
have dated Armstrong's boyfriend while
the two were broken up after Wilson's
death officials say Armstrong used
someone else's passport to flee to Costa
Rica where she dyed her hair and
underwent cosmetic surgery Armstrong was
later arrested and brought back to the
United States while she appeared in
court via zoom on Wednesday the judge
ruled the hearing could not be recorded
after a flurry of motions from both
sides the judge agreed to prohibit
discussions with the media as
proceedings continue this case comes as
defense attorneys voice concern for for
an unbiased trial based on widespread
media coverage
let Tony I'll start with you this time
listen the prosecution filed a motion
for a gag order then the defense filed a
motion to prohibit prejudicial comments
to the media
at the end of the day the judge
prohibited all discussions with the
media was this the right decision in
this case
look I've been a part of some pretty
high profile cases and I think it is the
right decision because here's ultimately
what they both have to make sure of the
defense and the prosecution you want to
make sure that you're able to see an
impartial jury and when you have a case
like this which everybody can know about
with social media you know about it it's
hard to find jurors who have not heard
something and then if you're out there
giving media statements then they're
having that opportunity to hear that
prior to you actually getting a chance
to do voidir so I think it was a very
good idea to do that in this case well
it makes sense you're not supposed to
try your case in the media both sides
should basically leave their arguments
for the courtroom
but Karen this is not a Johnny Depp
Amber Heard case I mean it's a big case
but doesn't the public have a right to
know about it even if it is a big case
yes the public does have a right to know
constitutionally we have freedom of
speech we have freedom of the press and
I agree with LaToya that that
information that's already out there on
social media it's going to be there the
judge doesn't have any control over the
media but the judge does have control
over the information that the attorneys
both the defense and prosecution are
going to put out about the case so the
gas can limit what the attorneys are are
sharing with the public regarding the
information in that courtroom it's the
judge's courtroom and the judge can make
the determination as to what information
should or should not be distributed to
the public on the other hand it makes a
lot of sense if both of the parties the
defense and the prosecution can have a
mutual agreement on what they're willing
to share or or what should be shared to
the with the public and what shouldn't
be I I couldn't agree more and I think
that judge has to make sure that it's a
tight hold on both parties so that they
don't Prejudice the case in one form
another and it looks like this case is
going to be delayed in any case so
hopefully it's not going to have an
effect on the outcome do you agree Karen
yes I agree and usually when with the
defense's position as a defense attorney
to help hold the delay it as long as
possible
thank you both for joining us today here
on alarm crime daily we'll see you next
time as we discuss Justice in America
[Music]
thank you
[Music]